el compromiso más grande que se espera
salga de esta cumbre del g7 es la
donación de 1 millones de dosis de
vacunas 1000 millones de dosis de
vacunas contra el cob y 19 para todos
los países en desarrollo claro es un
avance pero se cree insuficiente también
como has mencionado una parte importante
de esta cumbre se ha centrado en como
los países en desarrollo los más ricos
pueden tomar decisiones urgentes rápidas
las más drásticas que puedan para
acelerar todas las acciones contra el
cambio climático la prevención de las
especies de los océanos y controlar todo
lo que se pueda la temperatura global
una decisión bien importante que tomó el
g7 es acabar con las plantas de luz que
para producir energía requieren el uso
del carbón se aportarán recursos
millonarios para los países en
desarrollo para que no tengan que usar
este tipo de elemento porque se cree que
el carbón es el combustible más sucio
para el planeta también se ha
comprometido los
el g7 en reducir emisiones en
agricultura transporte fabricación de
acero también a proteger el 30 por
ciento del territorio global y de los
océanos para el 2030 y también se espera
que el g7 elimine gradualmente el uso de
carros de gasolina y de diesel